I think it's unfortunate that the first
major wildlife disease outbreak on the
world is affecting frogs because a lot
of people don't perceive frogs as
charismatic and cute and important but
frogs have amazing personalities
themselves they are just as important in
the environment as these large animals
as well and they're beautiful Kazuko
National Park is a montane cloud forest
in northwestern Honduras
there is amazing wealth of biodiversity
and especially for the reptiles and
amphibians it was recently assessed as
in the top 25 sites in the world for its
its unique and imperiled m15 diversity
makino remedial nombre yo tengo y NT da
yo yo vivo aqui en el parque see an
terminado muchas muchas Resendez drama
queens mess poco más poco menos Canton
ya know CIN cantar muchos la crea drama
Kaylin Dianna Solem Emma's CC necesitas
Albano's porque de repente a satyr
Maiden Sophie being captured fungus is
an aquatic fungal pathogen it's one of
the first wildlife diseases that has
truly gone global by the time we knew it
existed it's leading to one of the
largest mass extinctions that we have
ever documented I've been working
alongside Jonathan Colby since 2010 here
in Kazuko National Park through the
research that we've been doing we came
to understand that kitchen was greatly
affecting a lot of the populations of
frogs here and specifically some of the
endemic species frogs play a really
important role in the food chain so they
support many organisms and particularly
there's one snake species here does an
amphibian specialist soap raise almost
exclusively on amphibians and it's
fought to have population declines
itself which is almost as a direct
result of amphibian populations
as the tap hold metamorphosis into a
frog its immune system suppresses
because the tap hole begins to develop
totally new organ systems that of an
adult animal the stage of metamorphosis
is most often when they succumb to
disease from Kitteridge
we have now established the Honduras and
phibian rescue and conservation center
which means removing the younger weaker
animals before they die from featured
curing them raising them till they're
strong or healthy adults and then
reintroducing them what happens with a
lot of rescue efforts is you take
populations from the wild you get them
in captivity and then reintroduction
doesn't always happen so the plan for
hark I think is unique I think Hawk is a
fantastic initiative especially for the
conservation of these really special
species in the park a pleasure to see in
a natural environment and a little bit
if in future years I can see that
populations increase as a direct result
of it